I met the mountain John Observatory and  take a pose New Zealand  it's really beautiful everything about  it the clouds sleeping on the  mountaintops  the large body of still blue water  the cold breeze appreciate the little  town should be them everyone there is  individually busy or with their own  thoughts and dreams as this moment  passes but from a distance it looks just  as still as the water the moon more than  a rock pitch overhead it reminds me of  why I'm here of the mysteries and a  chance to look out at the rest of the  universe for this instant that I'm a  part of it being surrounded by these  things makes me glad to be alive just  for today to see the beauty like my  whole life is worth this moment this  moment of being an observer we are all  observers even if just for an instant